(whooshing)
(mouse clicking)
(electronic chiming)
(lively music)
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape,
bipedal, naked, large-brained,
long the master of fire,
tools, and language,
but still trying to understand ourselves,
aware that death is inevitable,
yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future
from our shared understanding of the past.
CARTA brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are
and how we got here,
an exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
(dramatic music)
(lively music)
- So I'm also very grateful
for this invitation.
I haven't been this excited
about death for a long time.
(audience laughing)
So just to set the context
of my talk a little bit,
you'll remember when Dora
presented the baboon slides
and the various questions
that we might ask
of those baboons
with respect to their
understanding of death.
What I'll be telling you,
I think, in part today,
is that the answer to
many of those questions
with respect to children
at a fairly young age
is yes, that they have an understanding.
But then I'll go on to say more
about how that understanding
might be displaced or amplified
by the notions of afterlife or religion
that their particular
culture presents to them.
So that's the gist of the presentation.
Some acknowledgements here.
My good colleague Rita Astuti,
whom you'll be hearing
more from this afternoon,
Marta Gimenez, with whom I
did some research in Spain,
three colleagues at the
University of Texas,
I'll mention them later
when I talk about some work in Vanuatu.
So, as I've said,
children probably acquire,
certainly by the age of seven or eight,
have acquired what we might think of
as a biological theory of death.
That's to say they seem to understand
that death is a terminal point
for all mental and bodily processes.
And indeed, children of this age,
seven, eight, nine,
it varies a little bit
from child to child,
also seem to understand
the universality of death
that it applies to everybody,
that it's irreversible.
And it's also true that they understand
something of the mechanics of death.
That's to say that the body is a machine,
that there are various parts,
invisible parts, lungs,
heart, and so forth,
which have to be coordinated,
and when those parts break down,
then death is inevitable
with various consequences.
At the same time, children will encounter
a religious account or
a supernatural account,
and part of what I want to discuss,
as I mentioned a moment ago,
is the relationship in the child's mind
between these two different accounts.
So in order to explore that question
of the relationship
between the two accounts,
we, that's to say myself
and Marta Gimenez,
tested children of five years of age,
sorry, seven years of age
and 11 years of age in Spain.
I mentioned Spain advisedly in some sense,
because of course, these
children were there
for growing up in a
particular religious culture.
The children were not just quizzed
about their, as it were,
immediate or biological
conception of death,
but we tried to prompt
their religious conception as well.
And we did this, therefore,
in the context of two different stories.
One about the death of a grandparent,
and at the end of the story,
the grandchild is visited by a doctor,
and the other, also about
the death of a grandparent,
but in this story,
the grandchild who's
lost their grandparent
is visited by a priest.
So I'll just show you those two stories.
As you can see toward the end here,
the doctor came to talk to Juan
about what had happened,
and he said to Juan,
"Your grandfather is dead now."
You can see that there
is no hint in this story
of an afterlife,
or there are no religious cues.
The second story, the priest's story,
is fairly similar.
That's to say, death of a
grandparent who's been ill,
goes to the hospital.
But as you can see, at
the end of the story,
Marta, the protagonist
is visited by a priest
rather than by a doctor
who explains what has happened,
and puts to Marta the claim that
her grandmother is now with God.
So each child listened
to both of these stories,
and after each story,
we would ask about
the functioning of various processes.
Sometimes, we asked
about bodily processes,
for example, have his
eyes stopped working?
And sometimes, we asked
about mental processes,
can he still see?
And as in this case, we
tried to choose pairings,
that's to say where we would focus in
on a bodily organ
and an accompanying mental process.
We couldn't always do that,
but roughly speaking, that was our goal.
So ultimately, the children answered
about 14 questions,
seven about the functioning of the body,
seven about the functioning of the mind.
The children gave their reply.
They would either say this
process was continuing or not,
and then we would ask them
to offer an explanation
of why it had stopped,
or conversely, why the
process was continuing.
And we found that we could
allocate children's answers
to three different categories,
religious, biological,
and a more equivocal set of replies.
So let's just present
the way in which we scored children
for each of those categories.
So religious answers, well, in this case,
the child would claim that
a given process continues,
so yes, he can still see.
And then they, when we'd say,
"Well, how is that?"
They would supply a religious explanation.
"In Heaven, everything can work
"even if she is dead."
"The soul keeps working," and so forth.
So you can see very
clearly in these cases,
references to religious notions,
Heaven, the soul, and so forth.
Now if we turn to the biological answers,
here the child claims that
the process has stopped,
and as you can see,
they're pretty blunt about why it stopped.
"He's been eaten by worms.
"He has no body, he's just bones."
"IF he's dead, nothing can work."
And then finally, no credit answers,
these were replies where the child
either didn't offer an explanation
or if they did so,
it didn't seem to fit in with the judgment
that they'd made about the process working
or not working.
So what I'm gonna do next
is just show you the replies
for the seven-year-olds,
and just to give you a heads up,
the biological answers are black,
I mean the bars are black,
the religious answers are white,
and in between, you'll see
some gray for equivocal,
so to speak.
More than that, I'll show you the extent
to which the child
offers religious replies
or biological replies or equivocal replies
with respect to those two story settings,
remember the priest story
and the doctor story,
and also within those two stories
for mental processes
versus bodily processes.
So here's, as I say,
an overview of the seven-year-olds,
and you can see, it's fairly black.
That's to say most of the time,
the children are giving
biologically-oriented answers.
And if you look at the
left-hand side of the figure,
where I've charted replies
for the doctor stories,
whether it be about the body or the mind,
you can see that biology is dominating.
But if you shift over to
the two right-hand columns,
you see that religion is beginning to
get a look in, so to speak,
more religious replies,
and the proportion of
biological answers is declining.
So in other words,
when you present the same child,
or, well, essentially the same child, yes,
a story with some religious cues,
they pick up on those cues
and they start to interpret the death
in a different context
or in a different fashion.
So that's the picture
for the seven-year-olds.
Now we can ask what we will,
might find with the older children,
with the 11-year-olds,
and the extent to which
biology might, so to
speak, consolidate itself,
or religion might consolidate itself,
or there might be some competition
between these two modes.
And here's what we find.
You can see that religion
is predominating,
especially when we've given the child,
as you see in the two right-hand columns,
those afterlife cues.
So if the priest is introduced,
whether the child is asked
about the body or the mind,
there's a lot of religious talk
in their replies and justifications.
So the next step that we took
was to ask,
given that we had presented each child
with two stories,
to ask how consistent any individual child
might be across those two stories,
and indeed, across
essentially the 28 questions
that we had asked them.
So at one extreme, a given child
might be consistently
biological in their answer.
They might assume that death is terminal,
and that's that,
no matter what the process
and no matter what the story context.
Conversely, they might
be consistently religious
in their answers.
And finally, we could
imagine an individual child
who shifts their ground
depending on the story context
or indeed, on the particular process
that they're being invited to think about.
So you'll see in the next slide,
again, these two age groups,
seven-year-olds and 11-year-olds,
but I'm gonna show you as
a proportion of children
falling into these three categories.
So here are the findings.
So you can see that the seven-year-olds,
as we might have suspected
from the earlier figure,
approach death from a predominantly
biological perspective.
On the other hand, if
you look at that red bar,
we do see some proportion,
about 30% of those seven-year-olds,
who are mixing it,
who go backwards and
forwards, so to speak,
between the biological and the religious,
and a small proportion
who are consistently religious.
Now if we turn to the 11-year-olds,
we might have imagined
that the consistently religious bar,
the white bar,
would be the one showing
the most sharp increase
between the younger children
and the older children.
That's not the case, as you see.
What we do see is a decline
in consistently biological responding
and an increase in this
mixed pattern of responding,
where the child,
depending upon the particular
question we've asked,
is inclined to offer a biological account
or a religious account.
More generally, I would say
these data fitted into other data.
It looks as if children
by the age of late, middle
childhood, so to speak,
have arrived at these two accounts.
They don't necessarily
think of the two accounts
as competitors with each other.
They think of them as
compatible with each other.
But it's also true,
and this is going a little
bit beyond the data,
but I think it's very plausible,
that the starting point for young children
is the biological.
So they arrive at this biological account,
of which, as I said earlier,
by seven or eight, they
realize is a universal account
and therefore, applies to themselves,
and it may be that that's the foundation,
ultimately, this biological account,
for their increasing appreciation
of the message that is offered
by religion, so to speak,
which after all, in some sense,
presupposes the biological account,
but then denies it,
which says death is not the end.
So there's a sense in which,
from our point of view,
we are seeing a somewhat paradoxical,
conceptual development here,
where conclusions that
the child has arrived at
from a relatively objective point of view
are going to be put aside or set aside
in part by virtue of religious teaching.
So there's a quick summary
of what I've just reported to you.
And as I've emphasized,
as children get older,
this mixed stance is
the one that dominates.
I'm going to give you a very quick taste
of Rita's talk by showing
you a map of Madagascar.
That's all I'm going to do.
I'm gonna show you a
picture of her field site.
She will tell you what happens
when you go to Madagascar and you repeat
this kind of interview
with children and with adults,
bearing in mind that in Madagascar,
we're not talking about
a Christian culture,
we're talking about a culture
which believes in the
existence of the ancestors.
So I'm gonna move on quickly
instead to Tanna, Vanuatu,
as you can see, off the
east coast of Australia.
And in particular, this island of Tanna
is one where my colleagues in Austin,
led by Christine Legare,
have been doing these kinds of interviews
with children, and indeed,
with adults in Tanna.
Okay, they took essentially
the design study,
the study design that I
described a moment ago
to Vanuatu,
but they also tested
adults in Austin, Texas,
and the basic question was
the extent to which we would
find a distinctive pattern,
particularly in Vanuatu,
or whether we would replicate
the basic pattern we'd seen in Spain.
One, it seems like a minor
methodological point,
but I think it's of greater significance,
in this particular study,
each participant was only
presented with one story,
not with two stories.
So you could argue,
looking back at the
results we got in Spain,
that the reason why children
showed this duality,
this coexistence of two accounts,
was precisely because the two children
had been presented
with two different narratives about death.
In this study then,
each participant only got one story,
and we'll see if nonetheless,
we get this pattern of mixed responding.
So that's the basic question.
And I'm going to show you now the results
that we got when we presented a story
with afterlife cues,
similar to the one that
I mentioned a moment ago,
with respect to Madrid in Spain,
but with certain cultural adjustments,
given the culture,
the two cultures, I should say.
So here are the findings.
Pretty straightforward as you can see.
In both places, we see that
the consistently biological
is in the minority.
In both places, we do see some individuals
who offer consistently
religious responding.
But the very clear result
is this prevalence of a mixed stance
or mixed responding,
both in the United States and in Vanuatu.
So that leads me to, then,
some overall conclusions.
It looks as if, from our data,
and actually, that's
echoed not just in Spain,
but also in Madagascar,
that young children don't really
pay much heed to the religious narrative
which is available in their culture.
They come to an understanding of death
in biological terms,
and more probing interviews,
and those I presented to you today
suggest, as I mentioned earlier,
that this is part of a theory
in the sense that the children
also can invoke various
unobservable bodily organs
and realize that the body is coherent
or has to work coherently
for life to continue,
and when life stops,
you see a termination of most processes.
So children have established that notion
by around seven or eight years of age.
As that theory or account is consolidated,
it seems as if they become more receptive
to the existing theological,
supernatural, or religious account
that exists in their culture,
but having said that,
it's not as if that religious stance
leads them to forget or suppress
what they know about biology.
So what you see among
large numbers of people
in all of these populations
is a tendency to oscillate
between the two accounts.
And to the best of our knowledge,
these two accounts are not perceived to be
in conflict with one another,
and I think Rita will present you
with more ethnographic
evidence this afternoon
that indeed, people move rather smoothly
from one account to the other.
Now let me just try to
say one or two words
about the broader implications then
of these developmental findings
for more comparative approach
that we will be reviewing
in the course of today.
So these developmental findings
may or may not point to
what happened in the
course of human history,
and they may or may not point to
ideas that we can bring to
primatology in particular.
Could it be that primates
have some minimal
biological understanding,
and should we assume that
the religious notion, of course,
would ultimately, in the human species,
build on that biological notion,
which is already hinted
at in our close cousins.
Let me stop there.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
(lively music)